what's happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we got ourselves a dose
trailer for Shazam Fury of the Gods of
course during my co-host John John how
are you I am excited Shazam let's do it
awesome and look who's back with us koi
genre what's going on first trailer
reaction in a long time first of the
year first in a while sequel to my
favorite dceu film all right that's
great to hear dceu haven't heard those
words in a while
please jump into Sam that like button
that that action verb makes sense and
ladies and gentlemen I wanted to mention
a couple of things I've been talking
with Eric vostner new rock stars I'm
going to be going on their their live
break room today at uh 3 P.M Pacific
Standard time and then afterwards Eric
Voss is going to be coming over here to
live stream with me at 4 30 p.m Pacific
Standard time so tune in let's see
what's going on in the Shazam trailer
[Music]
all right
annihilate everything so much
destruction of this realm can do nothing
to stop us
you are very menacing I just want you to
know that oh nice
a lot has changed in the last few years
universe is getting rebooted
all right here's the situation
the daughters of Atlas are coming to
hunt us
children's told the power of the Gods
are cool okay I feel like maybe I should
be writing all this down
you want these Powers come get them hey
Khaleesi
Khaleesi Another Game of Thrones
reference
all right
put some Rachel Ziegler
save the world
taking Freddie
I can't do this take my powers back you
came to me so you would take them back
right
it's our works kit
searching for worthy champion
Billy what are you doing I have to do
this we end this now well they're
showing us like the whole movie
the third Act
oh nice
love the mythology creatures
[Music]
foreign
nicely done good uppercut
fascinating another hip-hop trailer
thank you Warner Brothers I feel like
they showed us a lot in that trailer
perhaps there's a couple of twists and
turns that are not being
unveiled I thought that was a solid
trailer it was I feel like it's not
going to be as dark throughout as the
way this trailer is communicating but if
you combine like the first trailer with
this one feel like those are gonna be
the two tones right yeah they're much
more like the First Choice a lot more
the the tone of the first shazam movie
and then this trailer there's parts of
this that feel like they're sort of uh I
mean I don't know if people are gonna
feel when I say this but it feels like
there's somewhat riffing on the
destruction of like [__] like in BBS and
Man of Steel because like that last
moment especially reminds me of when
Clark fought doomsday and then uses the
spear to kill two dead and it looks like
he's sacrificing him do you think it's a
riff or do you think it's like uh you
know parallel I think it'll be a little
bit of a hodgepodge of both interesting
yeah poetry yeah I don't know they'll
make a joke out of it you know yeah but
the first trailer even like was
referencing the other Heroes as well and
I noticed they the two things I noticed
most about this trailer was one they
didn't reference the other Heroes at all
the only way like things have changed a
lot if you're in the industry you're
like that means a lot more and then if
you're not it's like oh that's true they
are kids now uh but and the other one
was this felt more like the first movie
to me than the first trailer and I was
very uh publicly like concerned after
that first trailer the sequel problem
felt like it had struck my precious
Shazam I love Shazam and I was afraid
this second movie had gotten too big
because the intimacy of Shazam the the
family element the the tight-knit group
and it feeling grounded in a surreal
World while their head surreal Powers
was the magic literally I was really
afraid when you add this much
destruction you add the gods it would
lose that and we got a lot of shazamly
here like even the little Nuance of like
Jack Dylan grazer's adult self and Adam
Brody like sliding around and being all
cool like that feels like those little
details that I want to see from these
great characters that I love this
trailer gives me a lot more hopeful it
seems like it kept it personal with the
life or death Stakes that's where they
wanted to keep it like the most
immediate and intimate was our lives are
on the line and should I give up my
powers of Shazam in order to save
everyone but John what are you thinking
of calypso and Helen Mirren and uh
yeah I'm excited to see them both and to
see Anthea as well I mean I like that
they're borrowing it seems like a good
amount of iconography and stuff like she
plunges the golden apple into the ground
with the you know the dragon behind her
so I'm I'm always kind of uh enjoying
when they bring in and they rip stuff
out of Mythology to inform these movies
and I guess these characters Calypso and
uh and hesper and them don't have as
much of a comic book origin so there's
also like a nice level of mystery here
as to like okay these clearly are not
one-to-one translations from mythology
so yeah I'm excited to see those takes
yes comic fan two uh more historically
minded knowledge
um why do they want to hurt exam I.E
that's a good that's an excellent
question because like I don't know my
best guess is they they are being
pitched here as the daughters of Atlas
And so Atlas is one of shazam's many
powers of the Gods and so I feel like
maybe they feel entitled to that why
does this kid uh get to be imbued with
this power and perhaps is he using it
with the utmost responsibility of a God
that would be my best I actually think
because they're so hell-bent on Revenge
because Billy Batson's only been Shazam
for a little bit I feel like older
Shazam perhaps the wizard oh like he did
something I feel like he'd probably
killed Atlas oh like Damon hansu yeah
like the wizard Shazam yeah oh
interesting I mean we've seen the
trailer twice and both times are
watching like they seem so pissed they
would be pissed off for that too
obviously yeah but it opens on Mount
Olympus which I do think is telling of
like we're gonna get some more history
like I don't think we'd go to Modern
Mount Olympus like hey what's up like I
think there's something we'll find that
demon hansu had done me too we don't
have as many Wonder Woman Easter eggs in
this trailer is the first one either
because yeah you see something like
Mount Olympus and you're like oh man
this would be prime for like get some
help from Diana but probably not now
yeah I'm curious to see what Billy
Batson's character Arc is going to be
because that was one of the best parts
of the first shazam movie was how
personal it was for Billy and and
everything involved with the family as
well and I don't really remember the
first trailer that well so I'm trying to
like a while ago I can't move this movie
four times yeah Fast and Furious jokes
I'm trying to combine my vague memory of
the first one and Eminem and this one
has Drake what is Billy's Arc gonna be
in here because ever something in the
first show that I sort of remember was
there are these feelings of like was it
like when he turns 18 he doesn't feel
like he's gonna be a part of the family
anymore they're not going to really care
like once he when he's an adult he slots
enough or is that a good thing that's
Mary's Ark more than his because
remember the actress that played young
Miss Marvel effectively is is not in
anymore because they've got the adult
one playing both so I wonder if it's
going to be like a matter of like he
sees that she when she hits Shazam stays
in that mode and he's like oh that's
gonna be me soon like there's a an
external source of maturation you know
what I mean yeah and these these kids
are growing up and this was filmed like
two years ago so they're like driving
now and in that first trailer I mean he
is like in therapy sort of trying to
figure out his place in the world he's
like all these other heroes are around
and they like have their thing and
they're so ingrained in me I'm just this
weirdo kid what do I do you know so it
seems like he's still trying to find the
exact right place both in the world and
I guess in the larger DCU that once was
yeah that's gonna be really hard to
recut a film if the goal was like
finding yourself in the DCU and now it's
like well yeah because the first movie
is about like finding your family and
accepting yourself and I could see where
that would be now accepting yourself
comma where you belong but in the macro
versus the micro and that would be a
good plot for a sequel is is the first
film you keep at micro and you lead in
family in the second film you keep that
heart like you were saying but go macro
to the world like where do you fit in
the world and I I love a good Walkabout
out story and I love Billy Batson for
that it's Shazam is about a
coming-of-age story as a superhero if
you make that big to the scale of gods
yes but now with all of these changes I
don't know if they can tell that story
we'll see we'll see how it all goes I
mean there's other things in here that I
was surprised to see and I suspected
something about Rachel did they confirm
who Rachel's uh Ziegler thought she was
one of the villains and then it looks
like it looks like she's one of it looks
like she's a sister in this trailer like
a good version right looks like her and
Freddie have a romance going on well it
seems like she is yeah the one of the
three of them that is like most
sympathetic and is probably here to be
like no no no no sisters and you know
that moment at the end with the dragon
and the and the sphere is the staff is
going to be like near the end of the
movie yeah like what that and that's
what made me think even more of BBS
remember that with the marketing so I
was kind of surprised by uh I legit
wanted to look away
I want to see this movie
but I'm like doing a reaction like it
would look really bad if I was like
yeah you're gonna be a bold move they
killed off Shazam I wonder if the
reshoots
yeah he sacrifices himself you're like
well there goes that family but if they
do it like so bvs style where he dies
and he's reborn
yeah I think that would be pretty pretty
cool yeah I don't know if it's going to
start a universe or end it and that's an
interesting question I've never had from
a trailer or just be part of one I don't
know if it can't this looks great I just
hope people come out what I noticed in
this trailer because it really looks
like the finale is at the baseball
stadium there's so much emphasis on
Calypso I feel like his Hesperia kind of
vanishes halfway through this trailer
yeah you're kind of getting the
impression ain't gonna be around I
wonder if it looks like she lands at the
baseball stadium maybe she sees that as
like a Coliseum like a holy place of
sport and then it ends there for that
reason like I'm wondering if there's
emphasis on because it seems like that's
Lucy Liu's arrival into the film and
then later it's where the climax is I
imagine the baseball stadium becomes
like a Coliseum and I do see Helen
Mirren just effing off she's got Dame
stuff there is a lot of speculation too
that she will be the sort of like uh in
the middle ground it's like anthea's
like the most sympathetic and then
Calypso is going to be like the most
villainous and then maybe hespera will
be in the middle and be this sort of
like oh which way is she gonna go
character and I could see them maybe
doing that who's Anthea Anthea is uh is
the third one who's you know the actress
his name Rachel yeah they confirmed
that's who she's playing yeah she's
credited as Anthea or at least that's
the that's the only broad speculation I
have seen around the internet she's
constantly credited as that oh damn I
didn't know that oh so they straight up
revealed it already I thought the
trailer was just like unless I have
access to some information but just
doing some amount of research about this
I mean yeah again they're not like
one-to-ones from mythology but yeah
that's who she's been credited as they
pitched them as a trio a Comic-Con like
the three of them is like you know yeah
I didn't know that
it was very sweet oh [__] because the
first trailer didn't show you any of
that yeah she's very slight in the first
trailer and I mean she's not like really
super focal here but she does get more
moments huh all right throwing down
against mythical beasts well fast and
fury of the Gods it's kind of a weird
movie to be coming out right now but but
I'll be there open tonight because I'm
excited for Shazam we'll see what
happens you don't stop reading other
Comics because other Comics end all
right you see you read the comics you
love I'll be there I'm looking forward
to it yeah and exactly if I seems like
he's got a good shot of being in this
universe well thank you for being here
thank you koi for stopping by thank you
John for you know doing what you got to
do thank you Greg thank you for being
here just as well steering the ship
thank you room
thank you thank you thank you audio
interface computers thank you
electricity Thomas Edison and Tesla
Brian Perry Brian we're gonna do an
acronym shout out for you but we're only
going to do it with bitching names ready
b stands for
bronchosaurus
yes Noble dinosaur take the R John R
stands for
rhinoceros take the Y Coy yo stands for
your Mighty yodel yo stands for it
I skipped ahead why o stands for
Octavius Spencer sure sure n stands for
uh Newton John comma Olivia yeah don't
worry we won't do the Perry thank you
[Laughter]
Tyler Perry sweets and delicious Harry
Mason re as it restarts the universe
Barry White there's been here Brian I'll
see you soon
thank you